d'après as dernier recensement il y
aurait 30 millions d'un de jardin sur la
planète c'est très sérieux et 200
d'entre ont envahi le parc de bagatelle
prétaille alors georges bigot et michel
levasseur vont nous faire découvrir la
diversité de cette population à bonnet
rouge vous allez voir que même les nains
ont commencé petit ils sont venus ils
sont tous là ils campent à bagatelle et
après avoir été classé kitsch justel
date récente
il semble qu'un phénomène de mode les
sortent du purgatoire du mauvais goût
leur population dans le monde est évalué
à 30 millions d'individus
actuellement il s'en fabrique 600 mille
par an dans la province de thuringe en
allemagne d'où ils partent à la conquête
des jardins voici les épousailles d'un
avec une rose de bagatelle
cette noce est l'oeuvre d'une
plasticienne aujourd'hui hélène
d'espagne qui nous montre que les
créateurs contemporains ne méprise pas
ses personnages au bonnet rouge
les enfants en tout cas sont heureux de
les trouver disséminés dans la nature
un peu comme des oeufs de pâques ce qui
fonde le statut du nain de jardin et
d'une un secours a été à l'origine des
temps la préhistoire le besoin qu'on lui
les hommes abandonnés de s'approprier
les richesses de la terre et seules les
personnes de petite taille était en
mesure de s'infiltrer dans les
infractuosités de la terre et d'en
rapporter les minerais dont l'homme a eu
besoin moment donné sont ils des
personnages inquiétants sont ils des
personnages bienveillant à chacun de se
positionner mais probablement dans la
représentation qui en a été fait on les
attirer vers un pas vers un côté
beaucoup plus bienveillant et plus
souriant que ce côté plus
plus surprenant peut-être plus plus aigu
du début le début c'est à dire
l'antiquité qui attribue est aux mains
des verts pu lier à la fécondité est à
la bagatelle plus tard à la renaissance
puis au xviiie siècle le nain de 20
personnages grotesques qui stigmatise et
les différentes catégories sociales
les enfants d'aujourd'hui comme ceux des
écoles de blois par exemple ont été
invités à réaliser en plâtre qu il y ait
des nains à leur convenance
ils s'en sont plutôt bien tirés ils ont
traduit à leur manière l'univers violent
et le monde ludique dans lequel ils
vivent dans cette grande parade des
mains leurs oeuvres ne sont pas les
moins inspirés